اوكي المفروض قيمه ما بنعرف هو حلو عربي
نحن حبينا نلعب على هذا الكلام خصوصا انه
قبل عاملين مسرحيه اسمها زنود الست
وبتحكي عن زند الاساس بالبيت عن عن مراه
قاعده بالبيت هلا هالمره عن ست البيت
فهالمراه عم نحكي عن طلقه فمن زود الست
لمفروكه لانه انفركت وفركتها
اللعب على الحلو كمان فيه نوع من السركاس
لانه حلو كتير لذيذ وفارسويت وهيك هو
بيطلع يعني المسرحيه مثل ما قالت كانوا عم
بيقولوا انه كوميدي بس بذات الوقت فيها
شيء مر عم نحكي عن قصص مهمه هي يعني بذات
الوقت بتسلي بس فيها مساج قوي
الولاد حضانه مشتركه يعني منشوف شو الانسب
لالهن ومنقرر سوا لا كيف لا مفروكه هي
مسرحيه كوميديه
واخترنا اسلوب الكوميدي لانه بالنسبه
لالنا الكوميدي فيها توصل
مساج بطريقه كتير مباشره يعني فيها كتير
تدقر العالم بلا ما تخفف من جديه الموضوع
مثل كل مره يعني مثل كل انسان فيه كل هذا
فنحنا منفرجيهم بهذه الطريقه ومنفرجيكي في
اوقات
بصير في مشاكل يعني كيف الواحد هو بيكون
في مشاكل بين حاله واوقات بالعكس بحن على
حاله
احكيني عربي لانه ما بفهم عليك
مسروقه هي قصه كل امراه وقفت الاعراف
وايضا القوانين سدا امام عداله قضيتها
سواء المتعلقه بالطلاق وما يتفرع عنه من
حق في الحضانه او ما يرتبط بنظره المجتمع
اليها واطلاق اداناته المسبقه بحقها لصباح
العربيه ريناد ويهي بيروت